un incendie catastrophique et un an plus
tard une pandémie
bâti au 12e siècle sur une ancienne
basilique
la cathédrale est dédié à la vierge
marie et justement c'est à elle qu'on
attribue le pouvoir de demander à dieu
des miracles elle est priée parce que
elle doit comme toutes ces maladies sont
miel ou péchés des hommes
elle doit intercéder auprès de dieu pour
qu'il soit sauvé d'une part dans l'au
delà mais aussi pour qu'ils croient
guéris déjà au cinquième siècle saint
marcel 9e évêque de paris geri la
population entière de la ville d'un mal
démarré en terrassant un dragon
il repose dans la cathédrale la
cathédrale a donc joué un rôle très
important en développant des processions
et en montrant l'ironique les gens
meurent dans d'atroces souffrances
empoisonné par l'ergot du seigle c'est
le mal des ardents etienne de senlis et
évêque de paris et le lévesque a autour
de lui sans trois mâts la lisent les
chroniqueurs pas un miracle celui de la
vierge mais aussi des reliques qui sont
là et en particulier les reliques de
sainte geneviève m6 ont été apportées
depuis sainte geneviève au quartier
latin jusqu'à notre dame
ce qui est tout à fait exceptionnel
grâce à cela
sur les 103 malades sans son gain la
relique la plus célèbre et la couronne
d'épinés du christ donné par le roi
saint louis
il y en a d'autres moins connus des
cheveux de la vierge marie donné par le
roi philippe auguste 290 il se trouve
que philippe auguste le roi est en terre
sainte mais que son fils aussi est
malade ils sont tous les deux malades de
10 centres et le miracle consiste
justement à la partir d'une procession à
ce que les deux
père et fils dans une continuité
formidablement dynastique
ça ne marche pas toujours charles ciss
le fou et bien morts de folie
notre dame de paris organise des
processions contre les inondations la
sécheresse toutes sortes de catastrophes
les hérésies les invasions les guerres
donc on a on a toute une série s'ils
voulaient de des processions qui sont
répétés à cocody de ces épidémies et en
général elle s'accompagne de procession
pour la guerre et pour la famille car
toute cette période du 14e siècle
connaît la guerre des s'entend bien sur
et beaucoup de résurgence des fans
devine la science a eu raison de ces
processions au 19e siècle
alors si vous voulez quelque part une
procession s'est d'ailleurs vous voyez
bien que en cas de peste
c'est une source de contamination
formidable
[Musique]
et
on l'a fêté pâques à notre dame quand
même cette année dans la cathédrale il y
avait en tout et pour tout sept
personnes jean michel leprince est du
canada
[Musique]